I thought the Cooney thing was true but
it's not
cuz I kissed my mom all the time and I
don't get cooties
somebody's I mean it's our girls when
they like them some of them I mean I
think pick on you a lot of the boys are
very shy a lot of the girls have crushes
on the boys earthquake girl are the
nicest girl ever I have one crush I met
him in Kindle a freckle on their nook
he's a little cute she normally wears
frozen shirts he kind of looks like
really cool
it was Sun outside so we put on
sunglasses and that just made him cooler
yeah yeah everything she wears I like
he's a good Jala he's good at kickball
she can hang out with anyone ever girl
just liked one category Danny likes
multiple ones I was playing game with my
friends and she has to join we like to
summer camp together
when we talk to him I get nervous I feel
happy when he's around me
we playing
and I'm wearing pink and some double of
the song I told you I Fenton and um
somebody was listening and they told him
whenever I tried talking to him
let's just say he runs I have to tell no
one
I would never told her right I have a
crush on she would be grossed out
oh I got a Dolly's I don't like dogs but
I have to I was just gonna make him a
note back my friend Greg would play
wingman and he'd find out what um the
girl that I liked was interested in I
took all the things that she liked mash
them up on a piece of paper and I wrote
a book for her she told NAT she was
going to leave to a different - Lego
camp tomorrow and I was like herself and
we're best friends and I he doesn't know
it she she doesn't know that but I think
she has a crush on me too